we're going to turn to some breaking
news now Britain's King Charles has been
diagnosed with cancer Buckingham Palace
announced that he would not be
fulfilling his public duties last month
the king spent several days in Hospital
for an enlarged prostate test then
identified a separate type of cancer
prime minister Rishi sunak wished
Charles well and said that he had no
doubt the king would be back to full
strength in no time well GGO is standing
by in London and son talk us through
firstly how this announcement was
made well it has been reported via uh
through Buckingham Palace as well uh
with the announcement that his majest uh
that King Charles while he has been
advised uh not to undertake any public
duties at this time he still uh will be
undertaking State business and official
paperwork uh he came back down from uh
Northfolk to to his home in London uh
and it was of course just a little over
a week ago that he was undergoing
treatment for benign prostate
enlargement at a private Hospital in
London now as far as we know that and as
far as what the palace is saying is that
this diagnosis of cancer is not to do
with the health issue that he has uh
with his prostate however this openness
that we're seeing from the palace as
well from the royal family themselves is
according to the Palace a way for the
king to encourage men especially men in
his age bracket he is 75 years old to
have their prostates checked and also to
have a more openness with regards
accountability with regards to his own
health as well uh and of course uh
another member of the family his
daughter-in-law the Princess of Wales
Katherine was also in hospital as well
having another uh health issue but also
with this uh atmosphere of openness that
is being seen with the palace they want
to make sure uh that whatever issues
health or otherwise that the royal
family are having that it is accountable
to the public and that if they can help
provide any health messages to the
public then this is the way that they
would do it but in the meantime apart
from undertaking his treatment on Monday
it will be certainly a slower timetable
that the king will be following given
his treatment and Sonia has there been
any indication as yet as to what type of
cancer this could
be no although they are being open there
is only so much information that they
are allowing to go into uh the public
field as it were uh but of course with
uh the particular type of health issue
that the King has been undergoing
treatment for for that benign prostate
uh enlargement uh it is certainly
obvious that this is a message a health
message that they're willing to kind of
get more men
in the age bracket to be to check out of
course uh it is sometimes underdiagnosed
and it can be deadly of course uh but
these issues of course pertain to the
fact that men of that age will succumb
to some of those health issues and while
we don't know exactly uh what kind of
cancer the King has been diagnosed with
certainly it is a reminder uh that other
people perhaps and the the royal family
themselves are not certainly not immune
from such conditions and it is certainly
something that they want to transmit to
the public here and obviously obviously
Sonia we await for further details
coming from the palace but we do we
anticipate any comments from the like of
likes of Prince William for
instance I think perhaps really that
will be left to the uh the household of
the king himself uh the Prince of Wales
will be focusing on his own remit and of
course it is his wife has also had has
under on uh treatment as well and her
own health issues and he's already
mentioned that he would be uh really
focusing on that and focusing on where
he can take over from uh or how he can
help out his father the King on certain
other duties perhaps fulfilling some of
the public duties that the king is
unable to do so right now uh but uh
unless uh there is more information
which has been okayed by the household
it is unlikely that the Prince of Wales
will speak on behalf of his father
unless there of course uh instructions
to do so all right Sonia many thanks for
that Sonia GGO there in London on the uh
breaking news that King Charles has been
diagnosed with cancer uh let's bring in
Richard PHS Williams now who's a royal
Watcher and commentator and public
relations specialist he joins us from
London a very warm welcome to you so um
the announcement made not that long ago
um what does this mean obviously in
terms of pce sorry King Charles's
ability to continue doing his doing his
duties so far as we understand U he will
be able to function with the most basic
say for example signing bills into law
that sort of thing I mean should it in
any future occasion which we must most
sincerely hope it does not mean that
there is anything that any form of
incapacity uh then there would be
there's a procedure whereby councils of
state would act for him I mean as things
stand this has of course been a shock as
your correspondent was noting uh he was
recently in hospital for a benign
prostrate en largement and it was then
that this form of cancer and we don't
know the details was spotted so
obviously this this is serious news how
much of a departure is it from what we
may have seen with previous monarchs
regarding how candid and open the king
and indeed the Royal household has been
about this
diagnosis it is something that's
completely new really I mean uh Thea
occasion for example when Queen
Elizabeth was in hospital there was uh a
reporter picking it up and then
disseminating the news Royals of course
would infam far prefer uh and indeed
we've seen this in the different
approaches of of the king and also of uh
Katherine Princess of Wales uh to their
various illnesses uh she has been as
open as she feels able to be when he had
the procedure
fory prostrate uh he shared it with the
nation The Hope was and indeed this has
been reflected in numbers of people are
looking at the National Health Service
website and also so more awareness of
this condition and this is what he's
trying to do so whereas at a very
difficult time for himself uh he is
thinking of how to help others and some
of these issues and of course is
frustrate issues for example are very
sensitive uh sometimes people put it off
and sometimes too late so in that sense
uh these uh statements from Buckingham
Palace uh are
groundbreaking of course the huge
question is is this survivable what is
what are the next steps has there been
any announcement from the palace
regarding
treatment uh we don't know details we
only know that he's undergoing treatment
as I understand it and this hopefully in
coming days as when is thought
appropriate we we will be updated
there's no doubt as I say it is a shock
if you actually consider that he was the
longest serving Prince of Wales in
history uh he's been on the throne since
the death of Queen Elizabeth in
September of the year before last a
relatively short Reign and it must be
sincerely hoped he's a very fit person
and there is no question of
his absolutely remarkable ability as a
sort of convenor King on environmental
issues on issues dealing with
interreligious understanding and so
forth as well as his constitutional
position
but there's no doubt this is bad news
and the nation will be I think somewhat
shocked by it what does this mean for
other Royals and their roles uh does
this mean we are likely to see the likes
of Prince William the Future King step
up to the mark to fulfill some of the
duties that King Charles will not be
able to continue doing while he's
receiving treatment for instance well we
expect uh precisely that to happen the
problem has been
that with the Princess of
Wales unwell and indeed unable to
participate in Royal engagements to at
least the uh uh the Easter period and
possibly longer thereafter I she was in
hospital for something like a
fortnite there's no doubt we it's just
been announced that the Prince of Wales
will carry out his first Duty on uh the
7th of uh February so that is relatively
soon but there's no doubt also that
there's talk of a Slimline Mony where
there are far fewer members of the royal
family able to carry out engagements I
mean we now have the king uh with with a
cancer diagnosis we had the Princess of
Wales most unfortunately um unable to
perform duties for a number of weeks
there's no doubt at all a lot will rest
on both the Prince of Wales and of
course Queen Camila who has been quietly
uh But conscientiously continuing her
duties but essentially uh we will have
to obviously wait and see what future
bulletins show and hope that the king
will as he undoubtedly would wish uh be
back and able to perform his duties very
soon that is of course the hope of many
many people there in the United Kingdom
Richard Fitz Williams uh many thanks uh
for joining us and just to repeat the
breaking news that we've received short
while ago as the Britain's uh King
Charles has been diagnosed with
cancer